und jetzt das heute journal mit
kaiselberichter und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend entweder man
ist selbst betroffen oder aber kennt
jemanden der betroffen ist mehr als
jeder zehnte bzw litt gerade an einer
Erkältung an Corona oder an der Grippe
und die Zahlen von akuten
Atemwegserkrankungen steigen von Woche
zu Woche waren es Anfang Dezember noch
7,9 Millionen sind es laut Robert Koch
Institut mittlerweile 8,9 Millionen
Menschen insbesondere die Influenza
Inzidenz ist dabei deutlich gestiegen
laut RKI lag sie zu Beginn des Monats
bei
1,76 Fällen pro 100.000 Einwohner das
ist eine satte Steigerung von
115% im Vergleich zur Vorwoche
Hausarztpraxen kommen da an ihre
Belastungsgrenze dabei hat die
Grippesaison noch gar nicht begonnen und
auch Kliniken kämpfen um Patienten gegen
Personalnotstand und gegen covid Petra
Otto es gibt wieder mehr Infektionen an
die 50 coronakranke im Stuttgarter
Robert Bosch Krankenhaus Monika ha ist
vorerkrankt und jetzt auch Corona wissen
Sie wo es herkommt nee genau weiß ich
nicht ne kann man auch gerade nicht
sagen die Lage irgendwie diffus auch
hier im Krankenhaus testen Sie nur
Verdachtsfälle Masken jeder wie ja mag
Corona hat zwar seinen Schrecken
verloren die Arbeit macht das nicht
unbedingt einfacher die schweren
Verläufe auf die sind wir relativ gut
eingestellt mittlerweile weil wir wissen
was wir tun müssen macht mir weniger
Bauchschmerzen wie die ganzen Patienten
die reinkommen und dann im Verlauf
positiv sind und dai die ganze
Belegschaft oder eine ganze Station
anstecken die derzeit kursierenden
Varianten hoch Anstecken der
Krankenstand unberechenbar dabei hieß es
doch immer die neuen Varianten die sein
nicht mehr so gefährlich covid ist kein
harmloses Virus geworden wir haben immer
noch das Problem des Long covids mit
erheblichen Ausfällen sehen wir auch bei
unseren Mitarbeitern und wir haben
weiterhin auch vereinzelt beatmete
Patienten auf unseren Intensivstation
aber sie können kaum noch Prognosen
Stellen früher gab es Inzidenzen nach
Landkreisen PCR-Tests hier im Robert
Bosch Krankenhaus zu zigtausenden
durchgeführt die Zeiten sind vorbei
coronadaten auch von Menschen ohne Test
und ohne Symptome kommen jetzt aus dem
Abwasser in Stichproben aus mehr als 100
käranlagen ist zu sehen die Viruslast
steigt rasant in den letzten Wochen
Jahreshöchststand der Klinik hilft das
wenig abwassermessung sind ein Parameter
der natürlich sehr stumpf ist für für
mich ist es besser eigentlich die Zahl
der stationären Patienten mit covid zu
nehmen die Zahl der Patienten auf
Intensivstation da haben wir
Vergleichsgrößen und deswegen sagen wir
ja wir haben es mit einem doch
deutlichen Infektionsgeschehen im Moment
zu tun Corona ist jetzt eine
ernstzunehmende
Atemwegserkrankung nicht mehr und nicht
weniger das Ende der Pandemie lang
ersehend doch wie damit umgehen denn
positiv sein und Weihnachten feiern ist
plötzlich kein Gegensatz
mehr das Bild ist vielleicht ein
bisschen verwirrender als wenn so ganz
klare Regeln geht gibt und man sagt okay
keiner darf zusammen feiern oder keiner
darf irgendwo hinein aber wir wollen ja
alle zu einer Normalität zurück dieses
Virus wird ja bei uns bleiben genau wie
andere Viren wie influenzer wiren und so
das auch tun das heißt wir müssen einen
vernünftigen Umgang damit finden und
selbst entscheiden wie mache ich es an
Weihnachten in der Notaufnahme rechnen
sie mit großem Andrang nach den
Feiertagen auch weil es keine klaren
Regeln mehr gibt es zählt wieder
Eigenverantwortung eigenverantwortung
ist gut und wichtig sollte aber auch
bedeuten sein Gegenüber mitzudenken
lassen wir uns die Gesamtsituation noch
mal ein bisschen genauer einordnen und
zwar von chihan cellig er ist Oberarzt
am Klinikum in Darmstadt spezialisiert
auf Lungenerkrankung schön guten Abend
guten Abend wie würden Sie denn die
Gesamtsituation einschätzen also wir
erleben momentan gerade einen steilen
Anstieg der Atemwegsinfektion das haben
wir die letzten Wochen auch schon erlebt
und jetzt gerade seit Anfang Dezember
ist diese erneute Anstieg steile Anstieg
getrieben von RSV Fällen bei Kindern und
unter jungen Erwachsenen das
Influenzavirus also wir kommen von einer
Phase einer virusdominanz in die nächste
momentan ist es so dass es vier Viren
sind die aktuell das Infektionsgeschehen
bestimmen und fast 9 Millionen Kranke
tendenzsteigend bedeutet wir werden auch
wieder mehr schwere Erkrankung in der
Klinik sehen das ist mathematische
Gewissheit und wir werden natürlich auch
viele Personalausfälle sehen dann
fokussieren wir uns jetzt mal auf covid
da haben wir gerade im Beitrag gehört
die Viruslast steigt die Varianten sind
hoch Anst ansteckend dennoch gehen wir
sozusagen als Gesellschaft aber auch im
politischen Raum damit um wie eine ganz
normale
Atemwegserkrankung ist das richtig oder
sollten wir doch etwas wachsamer sein
also zunächst aus klinikericht muss ich
natürlich ganz klar sagen dass im
Vergleich zu den pandemiejahren die
Gefahr die diese Krankheit für einen
Patienten dargestellt hat sich verändert
hat seit 2020 21 22 ist die individuelle
Gefährdung zurückgegangen aber covid
bleibt immer noch für viele Menschen ein
gefährliches Virus es ist nicht nur ein
atemwegserreger sondern eine
Systemerkrankung und es gibt viele
Menschen unter uns hochbetagte
vorerkrankte Krebspatienten die eben
sich nicht so effektiv schützen können
und diese Menschen sind aktuell sehr
stark auch gefährdet wenn die Inzidenz s
weit hochgeht und da stellt sich
natürlich die Frage ob man diese
bewerrten Maßnahmen wie z.B
maskenpflicht in bestimmten Bereichen
wie Krankenhäusern Praxen nicht etwas
schneller hochfährt um diese gefährdeten
Patienten einfach schneller zu schützen
ist das denn das einzige was sie fordern
eine maskenpflicht gerade in ähm sagen
wir mal vulnerablen Bereichen wie dem
Krankenhaus und dem Pflegeheim oder
gibt's noch was anderes da gibt es noch
mehr das ist ja das ganze Bündel das wir
jetzt auch schon kennen beispielsweise
eine verstärkte Impfkampagne eine
boosterkampagne unter den Menschen die
besonders gefährdet sind durch schwere
Verläufe von covid wir haben eine
boosterakzeptanz von 10% momentan mit
dem angepassten Impfstoff und das ist
nicht nachvollziehbar weil wir sehr viel
mehr Patienten über 80 haben oder
vorerkrankte haben die sich eigentlich
seit einem Jahr hätten schützen sollen
jetzt haben Sie die Maske gerade
angesprochen und auch das Impfen es gibt
einige in unserem Land die behaupten
dass beides daran schuld sei dass die
Zahlen jetzt gerade so massiv steigen
weil die wiederum also Maske und impfen
dafür gesorgt haben dass unser immun
Immunsystem so schwach sei was sagen sie
denn also das ist natürlich ein
Missverständnis dieses diese Theorie von
der immunschuld oder dem untrainierten
Immunsystem aufgrund der Maßnahmen
stimmt so nicht das ist ein viel zu
vereinfachtes Verständnis vom
Immunsystem so lässt es sich nicht
trainieren das Immunsystem braucht in
gewissen Abständen zu bestimmten
Erregern einen Kontakt um sein
Gedächtnis wieder aufzufrischen und wenn
das lange nicht erfolgt weil man z.B
Maske getragen hat dann muss dieses
dieser Kontakt wieder einmal bestehen
damit diese erährung aufgefrischt wird
aber das heißt nicht dass das
Immunsystem insgesamt geschwächt ist die
Gesamtlage richtig einzuschätzen ist
relativ kompliziert auch weil viele sich
gar nicht testen lassen das heißt es
gibt eine hohe Dunkelziffer sagen sie
leute lasst euch lieber testen damit ihr
auch wirklich wisst was ihr habt und
wenn ihr positiv seid auch ohne Symptome
bleibt zu Hause oder was ist ihr Rat
also ich denke momentan gilt wer krank
ist sollte zu Hause bleiben also weder
zur Arbeit gehen dieses Verhalten wurde
schon wieder verlernt habe ich das
Gefühl das machen immer mehr Menschen
auch nicht zum Weihnachts festgehen wenn
man sich krank fühlt ähm und es gilt für
alle vier momentan zirkulierenden
Erreger die Atemwegsinfektion
hervorrufen dass man nicht seine
Mitmenschen damit anstecken sollte daher
gilt die Devise wer krank ist hält sich
ein paar Tage zurück bleibt zu Hause und
wer positiv ist aber keine Symptome hat
auch weil sie haben ja gerade auch
gesagt es ist eben nicht wie eine
Erkältung oder wie eine Influenza
insbesondere wenn man weiter denkt dass
man andere infizieren kann die dann
andere Schäden long covid beispielsweise
davon TR richtig also zum einen würde
ich sagen bei einem Krankenstand von 9
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
aktuell ist die Zeit gekommen dass auch
positive ohne Symptome ihre Mitmenschen
schonen sollten damit das nicht noch
weiter in die Höhe geht und zum anderen
gibt es eben noch das long covidrisiko
was coronainfektion noch mal besonders
hervor stehen lässt das gibt es auch bei
anderen Infektionserkrankung aber bei
Corona eben noch viel stärker und
gehäuft und weniger verstanden sagt Chan
chelik vielen herzlichen Dank für einen
Besuch heute bei uns Oberarzt am
Klinikum in Darmstadt alles Gute und
bleiben Sie gesund sie auch
anderes Thema dass der Krieg in Israel
auch Auswirkungen über die Grenzen
hinaus hat sehen wir aktuell an der
Staatsanwaltschaft Dortmund dieser hat
ein
Todesermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet um
zu klären ob eine deutsche Familie
tatsächlich Ende Oktober bei einem
Raketenangriff in Gaza getötet worden
ist das jedenfalls behauptet ein
Familienangehöriger unbestritten ist
dass die Angriffe auch heute von beiden
Seiten weitergingen also sowohl die
israelischen als auch die der
Terrorgruppe Hamas deren zentrales
Tunnelsystem will Israels Militär jetzt
entdeckt haben Henriette
demia ein weit verzweigtes Tunnelsystem
unter der Stadt Gaza Bilder die das
israelische Militär veröffentlichte sie
zeigen unterirdische Tunnel mit eigener
Strom und Wasserversorgung Fahrstühlen
und einer Wohnung in bis zu 20 m Tiefe
he haben wir tunnelnetz im Hauptquartier
der Hamas zerstört mitten in gazaastadt
es handelt sich um ein verzweigtes
Tunnelsystem welches Verstecke und die
Kommandozentrale von hamasführern
miteinander verbunden hat die gestern
entdeckt wurden unterdessen gehen die
Kämpfe unvermindert weiter zuletzt hatte
es immer wieder Forderung nach einer
erneuten Feuerpause gegeben auch die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation schlägt
Alarm nur v
Gesundheitseinrichtungen im gesamten
Gasastreifen sind teilweise
funktionsfähig alle davon im Süden im
Norden gibt es tatsächlich keine
funktionierenden Krankenhäuser mehr es
fehlt an Treibstoff Strom medizinischer
Versorgung und Gesundheitspersonal es
gibt keine Operation
mehr auch die USA als die engsten
Verbündeten Israels haben immer wieder
zum Mäßigung und zum Schutz der
Zivilbevölkerung
aufgefordert hat auch heute noch einmal
sehr deutlich zum Ausdruck gebracht dass
es eine Rückkehr zu einer Pause und die
weitere Freilassung von Geiseln begrüßen
würde das Problem ist und bleibt die
Hamas die Reaktion von Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu gewohnt
kompromisslos wir kämpfen bis zum Sieg
wir werden diesen Krieg nicht stoppen
bis wir alle unsere Ziele erreicht haben
die vollständige Eliminierung der Hamas
und die Freilassung aller unserer
Geiseln und nach der Eliminierung der
werde ich alles daran setzen dass Gaza
keine Bedrohung mehr für Israel
darstellt und so sind die von der
israelischen Armee entdeckten und
zerstörten Tunnel eine weitere Nachricht
eine Fußnote in einem Krieg der bereits
76 Tage
dauert nach der Schießerei heute in Prag
verbreiteten sich insbesondere in den
sozialen Medien Gerüchte und
Spekulationen über Täter wie Motiv wir
bleiben in den Nachrichten kaisöve bei
Fakten und bei dem was wir wissen und
das wird stündlich mehr feststeht dass
mindestens 15 Menschen erschossen und 24
weitere verletzt wurden auch der
mutmaßliche Schütze ist tot er hatte das
Feuer an der Philosophischen Fakultät
der Karlsuniversität eröffnet
Studierende und Mitarbeiter
verbarrikadierten sich in Ihren Räumen
Anwohner sollten ihre Häuser nicht
verlassen zuvor hatte der Täter ein
Student der Hochschule seinen Vater
getötet außerdem gehen die Ermittler
davon aus dass er bereits vergangene
Woche zwei Menschen ermordete in der
Stadt herrscht Trauer und Entsetzen
viele Menschen legten Blumen nieder
ukrainische Männer die sich im Ausland
aufhalten sollen sich melden und für ihr
Land kämpfen dazu hat
Verteidigungsminister omerov aufgerufen
ein Sprecher stellte klar es sei keine
Zwangsrekrutierung geplant das hatte
zuvor die Bildzeitung gemeldet Anfang
der Woche hatte die Armee gefordert bis
zu 500.000 weitere Kräfte äfte zu
mobilisieren Deutschland hat dieses Jahr
mehr Menschen abgeschoben als im Vorjahr
bis Ende Oktober zählte das
Bundesinnenministerium mehr als 13500
Betroffene im gesamten Jahr 2022 waren
es knapp 13 000 hauptzielländer waren
Österreich Georgien nordmazedonien
Moldau und Albanien besonders stark
angestiegen ist die Zahl der
Abschiebungen in die
Türkei
bundesinnenministerin Cesar befürchtet
auch in diesem Jahr massive
silvesterkrawalle durch den narostkrieg
könnten Sie zusätzlich angeheizt werden
sagte sie dem redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland dieses Mal sei die Polizei
aber besser darauf vorbereitet als im
vergangenen Jahr damals wurden in
mehreren Städten Polizisten und
Rettungskräfte angegriffen besonders
heftig war es in
Berlin ja erst dort in der Hauptstadt
jetzt in ganz Deutschland die Landwirte
protestieren weiter gegen die Sparpläne
der Bundes Regierung durch Stuttgart
rollten sie mit mehr als 1000 Treckern
und legten teilweise den verkehralm und
bei Görlitz blockierten sie mehrere
Autobahnauffahrten um Geld zu sparen
will die Ampelkoalition unter anderem
die Vergünstigungen beim Agrardiesel
abschaffen drei Nachrichten heute die
die Fußballwelt bewegen die eine
betrifft die rundums geisburghheim der
erst fC Köln und Trainer Steffen
Baumgart gehen nach zweieinhalb Jahren
getrennte Wege ein vernehmlich wie es
heißt in Dortmund darf der Trainer
dagegen bleiben die Verantwortlichen des
BVB wollen weiter mit Edin tersitch
zusammenarbeiten die dritte Nachricht
hat eine größere Dimension der
Europäische Gerichtshof hat in einem
Grundsatzurteil die Monopolstellung der
UEFA für europäische fußballwettbewerbe
gebrochen das heißt der Verband darf
Vereinen und Spielern nicht verbieten an
anderen wenn Sie so wollen UEFA oder
FIFA freien Wettbewerben teilzunehmen
geklagt hatte die European Super League
company in der aktuell nur noch Real
Madrid und der FC Barcelona aktiv sind
zwei Vereine die dringend Geld brauchen
Christoff
Schneider als der europäische
Gerichtshof am Vormittag seine
Entscheidung zur Superleague verkündet
ist die Überraschung bei vielen
Beteiligten groß vor einem Jahr sah der
zuständige Generalanwalt bei den
Monopolisten UEFA und keine Verstöße
gegen europäisches Kartellrecht doch das
sehen die Richterinnen und Richter in
Luxemburg heute ganz anders UEFA und
FIFA würden sich wettbewerbswidrig
verhalten das sehen auch
sportrechtsexperten so Regel sagen der
Monopolist darf nicht diskriminieren
muss die wettbbsrechte einhalten muss
die freizügigkeitsrechte der
Arbeitnehmer beachten ja und das muss
jetzt die U FIFA zur Kenntnis nehmen und
dementsprechend sich verhalten heißt die
von spanischen Vereinen angestrebte
Gründung einer europäischen Superleague
darf von UEFA und FIFA nicht untersagt
werden das wäre sonst ein Missbrauch
ihrer Monopolstellung ein Erfolg für die
spanischen Clubs die das Superleague
Projekt weiter vorantreiben wollen doch
die UEFA bleibt nach der Entscheidung
gelassen weiß viele europäische Länder
hinter sich sieht die Unterstützung der
Superleague aktuell nur durch spanische
Vereine die deutsche fußballiga DFL
unterstützt die bestehende Wettbewerbe
der UEFA und auch Bayern München
schließt sich dem an die Bundesliga
bildet das Fundament des FC Bayern
ebenso stehen wir zu den europäischen
clubwettbewerben unter den Dach der UEFA
und Dortmunds Clubchef Watzke bekräftigt
dass der BVB für eine Superleague nicht
zur Verfügung steht und auch hierzulande
gibt es kaum Sympathie für eine neue
Superliga weil die kleinen Vereine dabei
auf der Strecke bleiben
und als ehemaliger Fußballspieler wie
viel Spiele soll ollen die Profis noch
machen ja teilweise in einer Saison
spielen die schon 50 60 Spiele W ich
nicht so gut we dann wahrscheinlich die
ganzreichen immer stärker werden eben
und die kleinen keine Chance haben gar
nicht aufzusteigen also ich bin
Stuttgart Fan von ich weiß was zweite
Liga bedeutet die füro die superl zu
viele Spiele Verletzungsgefahr und
Wettbewerbsverzerrungen Argumente die
die Gegner der Superleague sehen in
England ebenfalls keine Zustimmung die
dortige Regierung will zudem4
ein Gesetz erlassen dass jede Initiative
zur Gründung einer privaten Superliga
blockieren würde und auch der
italienische Fußballverband bekennt sich
zum Schutz nationaler
Meisterschaften die Tür zur Superleague
sie ist geöffnet aber wer und wie viele
am Ende durchgehen können
offen dass die Gewerkschaft werdi im
Tarifstreit ausgerechnet zur
Weihnachtszeit den Einzelhandel immer
mal wieder bestreikt ist jetzt aus Sicht
der Einzelhändler eher suboptimal zumal
das Weihnachtsgeschäft eh nicht ganz so
gut läuft wie erhofft Inflation Geld
sorgen und eine in Teilen ungewisse
Zukunft dürfte den einen oder die andere
Bremsen vielleicht ändert sich das noch
für Geschäfte und Läden so Kurzform fest
denn ab heute können Onlineshops eine
rechtzeitige Lieferung wohl nicht mehr
garantieren Jan Hofer beginnt aber
seinen Beitrag mit dem Blick in einen
finanzstarken
Mikrokosmos hier brummt es auf der
Düsseldorfer Königsallee ist man in
Kauflaune teure Geschäfte für Leute mit
genügend Geld jetzt vor Weihnachten
wollen viele sich selbst und der Familie
mal was gönnen das was mir gefällt ziehe
ich über passt fertig meine kauflune ist
jetzt nicht reduziert und ich gehe auch
gerne einkaufen hier in Düsseldorf wir
verspüren die Unsicherheit aber das hat
uns bisher nicht eingeschränkt
Ortswechsel derselbe Tag ein ganz
anderes Bild in der Fußgängerzone in
Oberhausen ist es eher ruhig jede Menge
leerrstand die Arbeitslosigkeit hier ist
hoch viele Menschen leben von
Transferleistungen und kaufen nur das
nötigste das spürt der schuhändler Axel
Lambert deutlich mit seinem Umsatz ist
er dieses Jahr nicht zufrieden
Energiepreise Inflation und alsoas
spielt eine ganz große Rolle auch die
die Transferleistung die einige beziehen
die jetzt zwar ab 1 höher werden aber
das das zieht doch schon ganz schön am
Geld und dann überlegt man sich zweimal
ob man was kauft oder
nicht so geht es zurzeit offenbar vielen
im Land die allgemeine Stimmung ist eher
gedrückt analysiert der Konsumforscher
Rolf Bürkle vom Nürnberg Institut für
marktentscheidungen viele verbrauche
sind nach wie vor stark verunsichert
durch die multiblen Krisen durch hohe
Lebensmittelpreise und aktuell kommt
jetzt noch der Streit um die
Haushaltssanierung hinzu auch hier
befürchtet der eine oder andere
Konsument sicherlich dass er stärker
belastet wird in der
Zukunft in den kommenden Tagen wollen
sich die meisten Deutschen trotzdem
etwas gönnen leckeres Essen oder
Geschenke Weihnachten ist nach wie vor
der Anlass zu konsumieren dafür habe ich
gespart leg jeden Monat etwas beiseite
ich sag mal so zwischen 100 200 € jetzt
für alle Familie Freunde Freund dies
das insgesamt aber ist der Handel
unzufrieden die Bilanz schlecht übrigens
für den stationären genau wie für den
Onlinehandel es sind ja dieselben
verbraucherinen Verbraucher die aufgrund
ihrer Kundenerwartung und aufgrund der
Unsicherheit die wir momentan haben
weder im interneteinkaufen noch
stationär so dass es das gleiche
Kundenverhalten ist und wir insgesamt
für das Jahr 23 im einzeln leider von
einem Minus ausgehen müssen für das
kommende Jahr übrigens ist die Bran
optimistisch der Handel hofft auf eine
niedrigere Inflation und wieder höhere
Umsätze und diese Hoffnung hat einen
Grund nämlich die Aussicht auf steigende
Löhne und Gehälter und die macht auch
die Verbraucher optimistischer was genau
erwarten die Wirtschaftsforscher für das
kommende Jahr Valerie Haller also
gesamtwirtschaftlich sehen Ökonomen für
das kommende Jahr eher geringe Chancen
für eine Erholung einziger Lichtblick
könnte tatsächlich der private Konsum
sein weil wie schon gesagt die die
Einkommen deutlich steigen und die
Inflation zurückgeht bei den
Verbrauchern hält sich allmählich die
Stimmung wieder etwas auf in der
neuesten Studie zum Konsumklima heißt es
die Menschen hätten wieder etwas mehr
Kauflaune wie nachhaltig das ist wird
davon abhängen ob die Inflation weiter
abppt und es Lösungen für die aktuellen
Krisenherde gibt denn am Ende
entscheidet auch das Vertrauen ob die
Menschen konsumieren oder eher sparen
und wenn sie konsumieren ist die Frage
wo sie das tun und da zeigen um Fragen
dass sie wohl offenbar wieder häufiger
in den Laden gehen ist der Online Boom
gebrochen also zumindest normalisiert
sich das Einkaufsverhalten wieder nach
dem großen Boom in der coronazeit der
Anteil der Internetkäufe geht schon das
zweite Jahr inf Folge zurück dieses Jahr
waren es im Schnitt 30% also fast jeder
dritte Einkauf wird online getätigt das
ist ungefähr so viel wie vor der
Pandemie ob das starke Wachstum beim
Internethandel wieder zurückkommt unklar
die Börse scheint derzeit nicht darauf
zu setzen das kann man an den teils
schwachen Aktienkursen von onlinehändern
wie Zalando ablesen danke
schön ab dem 8 Januar müssen sich
Bahnreisende ja wieder auf Streiks
einstellen und was da genau auf sie
zukommt das hat jetzt gdlchef wiselski
erklärt sollte die Bahn kein neues
Angebot vorlegen werde man für dre bis 5
Tage streiken sagte er der Rheinischen
Post einen unbefristeten Ausstand plane
man nicht hauptstreitpunkt zwischen Bahn
und lockführergewerkschaft ist die
geforderte Absenkung der
Wochenarbeitszeit es ist weiterhin
gefährlich im isländischen grindavwiik
aber immerhin dürfen die Menschen dort
tagsüber wieder in ihre Häuser der
Vulkanausbruch hat sich etwas
abgeschwächt vor drei Tagen hatte sich
eine Kilometer lange Spalte aufgetan aus
der Massen von Lava sprudelten
inzwischen tritt sie nur noch an
einzelnen Stellen aus die Behörden
hatten das Gebiet schon vor Wochen
evakuiert
und auch das Wetter in Deutschland ist
nicht ganz ungefährlich in den
westlichen Mittelgebirgen im Harz und im
Oberallgäu warn der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor ergiebigem Dauerregen
und an den Küsten und in den Bergen vor
orkanbönen schuld ist Sturmtief soltn
das im Norden den Bahnverkehr
durcheinander wirbelt an Elbe Weser Ems
und Nordsee müssen sich die Menschen auf
eine schwere Sturmflut einstellen
zwischen dem Festland und den Halligen
fahren derzeit keine fären und an der
Ostsee wurde die die femann sundbrücke
gesperrt aktuelle Infos zum Sturmtief
hat östen terli dann später im
Wetter die kulturelle Identität bewahren
indem man die Welt in und um sich herum
zum Klingen bringt so könnte man das
beschreiben was ukrainische exilmusiker
seit nun mehr 20 Monaten machen kurz
nach der russischen
Invasion in ihrem Land gab das meria
Orchester sein erstes Konzert in Hamburg
über weitere sollten folgen gestern
Abend spielten sie erneut in Hamburg
gegen die Zerstörung der ukrainischen
Kultur gegen das Schwinden der
Aufmerksamkeit und gegen die
Ermüdungserscheinungen in Bezug auf die
Solidarität Martin
nien Maria nennt sich das kurz nach
Kriegsbeginn gegründete Orchester
übersetzt Traum für die aus der Ukraine
geflüch Musikerinnen und Musiker ist es
vor allem der Traum von Frieden und der
Rückkehr in ihre Heimat die sie Hals
über Kopf verlassen mussten manche sogar
ohne ihre
Instrumente das Cello war zu schwer um
mich herum so viele Menschen und große
Panik mir wurde klar dass ich unmöglich
mein Cello und meinen Kater mitnehmen
kann also entschiede ich mich für den
Kater seitdem spielt Olga drieger mit
einem Geli Cello werpflichtige männliche
Mitglieder des ensembls hatten die
Ukraine nur mit einer Sondergenehmigung
verlassen können als eine Art Kämpfer an
der
Kulturfront es ist sehr wichtig dass ich
hier arbeiten und damit die Ukraine
repräsentieren kann ihre Kultur und
Musik dafür gebe ich mein
[Musik]
Bestes in einer Kirchengemeinde im
Hamburger Osten Prob leen Chor für den
großen Auftritt mit den Profimusikern
der Chor besteht aus geflüchteten und
Ukrainerinnen die schon länger in und um
Hamburg wohnen der Krieg hat sie
zusammengeschweißt es ist natürlich sehr
sehr schlimme Umstände mit dem Krieg
aber anderserseits wir haben uns hier
gefunden und das bringt Kraft und
wirklich Stück Heimat weil das vermisse
ich sehr denen sitzen einige noch bei
chleiterin Julia zock zusammen tauschen
Erinnerungen an und Nachrichten aus der
Heimat aus und auch sie sehen sich als
Kämpferinnen ihre Waffe die
Musik wir führen unsere Kultur und
unsere Traditionen hier fort und geben
sie weiter das ist unsere Mission und
Botschaft an alle Ukrainer die in der
Heimat geblieben
sind am Abend stehen sie mit den
Profimusikern deschesters auf der Bühne
trotzen russischer Aggression mit einem
ukrainischen
Volkslied geeint in der Hoffnung dass
sich der Traum vom Frieden bald
[Musik]
erfüllt und wer will sich diesem Traum
nicht anschließen ja wir sind dabei wir
sagen tschüss und empfehlen Ihnen noch
das heute journal Update um 11:15 Uhr
mit Christopher wermann das war's von
uns machen sie es gut wo auch immer sie
sind
[Musik]
tschüss schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja der Sturm hat
ja ganz Deutschland im Griff und hier
sind einige Station einige ausgewählte
wir sehen hier spiieerok mit 140 km pro
pro Stunde das sind schon gefährliche
Geschwindigkeiten die durchaus
lebensgefährlich sein können auch in
Bremerhafen noch 115 km pro Stunde die
es heute gab und die Frage ist natürlich
wie geht es weiter und hier haben wir
regen der quasi südwärts zieht und sie
sehen hier die Blitze Aufflackern es
sind also auch einige Gewitter dabei und
in der Nähe der Gewitter sind solche
Windgeschwindigkeiten um 100 km pro
Stunde und drüber durchaus möglich das
ganze wandert zwar langs südwärts aber
neue Schauer und Gewitter Schließen von
Nordwesten an ja und die Großwetterlage
sieht folgendermaßen aus der der Wind
ist ja eine Sache aber hier zieht noch
weiterer Regen auf und tatsächlich auch
einige weiße Flächen das bedeutet es ist
auch Schnee dabei der bleibt allerdings
nicht liegen und in der in der nächsten
Stunden haben wir es ja auch noch mit
sehr viel Wind zu tun vor allem Richtung
Ostsee durchaus Windgeschwindigkeiten um
130 km pro St Stunde örtlich kann das
mehr sein ansonsten 60 bis 100 km pro
Stunde auch in der Nähe von Schauern und
Gewittern ist das der Fall ja und in der
Nacht also weiter Regen der weiter nach
Süden zieht und von Norden her teilweise
auch Auflockerungen und das bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 8° im Südwesten und 1°
z.B Richtung Berlin morgen weitere
Schauer vor allem im Norden die ziehen
südostwärts der Wind legt ordentlich zu
an der Küste Richtung Ost und auch im
Südosten ansonsten kommt dann neuer
Regen von Westen her auf ja und die
Temperaturen dazu maximal 3 bis 11° und
die nächsten Tage ja am Samstag noch
viel Wind und Regen bei 2 bis 10° und
heilig abends ziemlich durchwachsen
regnerisch und windig ein schönen Abend